why did we miss the San Bernardino
couple it was because i think as someone
who comes from the technology world we
were using the wrong algorithms they
have to give law enforcement the ability
to listen so they can disrupt these
terrorist attacks before they occur this
is a place where the private sector
could be helpful because the government
is no fully behind the technology curve
we should be using our brilliant people
are most brilliant minds to figure a way
that Isis cannot use the internet
member
the next time there is attack on an
attack on this country the first thing
people are gonna want to know is why
didn't we know about it and why didn't
we stop it and the answer better not be
because we didn't have access to records
or information that would have allowed
us to identify these killers before they
attack